there the beauty of this game is
something like Jose Altuve grew up in
Venezuela playing baseball on the
concrete tried out for the Astros they'd
sent him away he kept kept pushing and
now he has the second most home runs
Pedro Martinez in postseason history and
three quarter three quter of the way to
the hall of fame already earned I think
altu is going to end up his career if
I'm not mistaken and I'm praying to God
that he stays healthy as the best second
baseman that ever played the game game
probably in the postseason and in the
regular season that's how high I think
of of Al I think what he's done is great
I think he's young enough to still pile
up some more numbers especially in the
postseason I mean what haven't we seen
from altu if you watch the big vloggers
in the postseason he's right there with
them in homers RBI total bases amount of
games amount of a bats and and his
average and everything and and then his
defense which was the weak link that I
saw in altu has gotten so much better
this is a complete package in a small
frame they say that great colog come in
a small bottle well there you have it
the best cologne out there I'll pay I'll
pay anything for that
cologne remember the direct story that's
why good all the time hey did y'all
sneak some coffee car remember that yeah
yeah I mean oh I want cool water though
you know what's going on brother no I'm
just I love it I love it I'm here for it
yeah I love that's how much I love I'll
pay anything for that perfume it's
approach it's pitch selection it's zero
ego you need a little bloop I'm here to
give you a little bloop and all about
passing the Baton and he acknowledged
that the runners got on beforehand if he
hits a solo shot like we've been seeing
throughout the playoffs it doesn't do
anything I need to have some traffic on
the bases you get a hit you get a walk
you pass to the next man in the lineup
now we go ahead and do damage with the
swing that's what the analytics are get
on and then hit the ball out of the
ballpark I couldn't help but think it's
experience with the zero heartbeat of
the Houston Astros vers new to this
stage in the Texas Rangers when I watch
game five uh I I don't see it that way
no not at all I mean Texas has been very
game this is a team that they've played
all season long they're very familiar
with each other uh Texas has a guy or a
couple guys that have been in playoff
Seager um being a champ their game their
manager Bruce Boi who's won three of
with the Giants they're ready this is
just a matter of executing uh pitches
timely hitting and we've been standing
on both sides is just that when the
teams get on the road they seem to step
up more than they've done at home we've
seen errors we've seen guys make great
defensive plays to swing the momentum
and the other side no I said no we're
not going out like that so it's just a
wellplayed game two well-managed teams
and two teams that are ready for the
moment games doing his thing for the
Texas Rangers uh we are very interested
in finding out who Pedro's daddy is
let's take a look at the nominees one
more time one more time I love how Lee
singles you up Alec Thomas is the leader
in the clubhouse because the NLCS was on
our air Jose Altuve the hero in game
five of ALCS in Arlington Texas where
are you leaning
Pedro how does Marena have less than sh
the game I
uh I I'm going to wait a little bit I'm
going to wait a little bit cuz every one
of them could be my daddy I need I
really I I need the DNA yeah yeah it's a
conclusive he wants he has to get reswab
you know he's already picked it
23 have you touch the have you text your
mom get a first name get can we get a
first
name last name